president trump is making inroads you
know among the small
majority of the electorate or you know
more voters than biden
he is doing well with groups that the
democrats have typically relied on
groups identity groups that democrats
usually take for granted
most notably in recent days among gay
guys
yes that's right the homosexual
population
of the of the electorate tends to be
taken for granted by the democrats and
yet according to polling
from a queer dating app right now it
looks as though
45 of queer american men now don't
cancel me for saying that that's their
word i don't know what word i'm supposed
to use they change the words every day
but 45 of queer american men are backing
president donald trump and this is
considered a very queer fact
because democrats always believe that
they're supposed to get 100
of the gay guys the app is called hornet
and uh 45 of them are going to vote this
is a
1200 queer american male respondents say
they're going to vote
for trump how did they get to this 10
000 men were surveyed by the app 12
identified as u.s citizens
51 said they'd be vote of those men said
they'd be voting for biden
and 45 for trump so it's very very close
even among
gay men and by the way these are just
the gay men who are on these apps
presumably
the more bourgeois stayed you know calm
gay men who are not on these apps
presumably they're even more
conservative than all that
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts